je vais faire passer une vibration en
montant comme ça votre cheveu c'est une
méthode qui peut paraître tiré par les
cheveux mais ici on les coupe plutôt en
quatre sophie lebouc pratique la coupe
énergétique depuis huit ans une
technique de bien-être psycho capillaire
c'est premièrement faire de la musique
avec les cheveux voilà et c'est
travailler sur la déprogrammation
cellulaire donc le principe en fait de
tendre les cheveux donc les cordes et
d'émettre une vibration avec mes coaches
où les coûts sont les lames utilisé par
soufi pour tailler les cheveux des lames
de 7 cm représentant sept notes de
musique par la vibration contact du
cheveu cette vibration elle va aller
aussi contacter le cortex donc le cortex
c'est la membrane qui entoure les deux
lobes du cerveau ça passait par les
oreilles interne et ça va passer par le
liquide céphalo rachidien
c'est pour ça que ça faisait partie en
fait des techniques où le mental il peut
pas intervenir c'est le corps qui lâche
qui peut au moment où il peut le cheveu
est ici les régions baromètre du kof
pour calmer ou stimuler les organes
c'est vrai que le cheveu c'est le
baromètre justement parce que ils
pompent le son il se nourrit du sang
donc bas suivant si on est en carence si
on a un problème pour savoir quand même
que le cheveu quand il ya un problème au
niveau d'un organe en habit sert le
cheveu lui c'est le premier au courant
parce que le sens il est vicié et donc
le cheveu lui il le sait déjà
j'ai détesté les coiffeurs longtemps
parce qu'ils vous il vous écoute pas ils
vous entende pas quand je sors d'ici je
vais mieux
donc c'est quand même plutôt vague à ce
qui devrait être ordinaire d'un coiffeur
mais ce qui n'est pas la coupe
énergétique une technique française
inventé par rebih portrait qui est pour
l'instant le seul à dispenser cette
formation une méthode basée sur l'écouté
du corps pour une meilleure harmonie et
bien-être